quite the interesting bit of Cassie news
has come out about one of the upcoming
Star Wars shows Abigail Thorne YouTuber
playwright professional actor has been
cast in Star Wars acolyte we do have a
name for the character Ensign Uris but
we don't know anything else about the
character that she is playing yet this
is still however pretty big news we
don't have all that many big name or
recognizable or well-known transgender
actors really at all it's a handful at
best and even some who had some heat a
little while ago like Laverne Cox have
kind of faded a bit more into the
background she's still working to be
clear she didn't go anywhere but no
longer in the Limelight so just
more transactors getting work especially
in something as notable as Star Wars I
applaud it I still don't know if I'll
watch the show I'm kind of burned out on
Star Wars a little bit other than Andor
we'll see how I feel about it when a
trailer eventually comes out but
congratulations Abigail